a disaster of quantum proportions or a
misunderstood cult classic in the making
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania has
fans divided up to this point the
exploits of Ant-Man in his solo Marvel
Cinematic Universe movies have been
pretty grounded size manipulating
superheroics aside the first two Ant-Man
films are fun Breezy and action-packed
Heist Adventures that don't raise the
stakes too high those were the days
whatever happened to us not the time
Scott however it seems that the days of
Ant-Man flicks of this variety are long
gone Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
brings our favorite micro Heroes on the
quest of a lifetime as they Venture into
the mysterious Quantum realm the home of
the dangerous Kang the Conqueror while
there's certainly a lot going on in
Kwanza Mania the reception toward it has
been relatively mixed in addition to
fans drawing embarrassing visual
comparisons between its and Spy Kids 3D
game Over it's not doing so hard over on
Rotten Tomatoes either early reviews of
the film put it at a disappointing 48
rotten critic score making it one of the
worst rated MCU film entries to date
next to 2021's eternals what did I miss
nothing just
screams of my deep disappointment
meanwhile folks on Twitter have begun to
post their thoughts on the long-awaited
Ant-Man 3 core with Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania finally Upon Us here's
what Twitter has to say about it first
of all despite the mediocre early Rotten
Tomatoes scores it's abundantly clear
that a good portion of the MCU funbase
is more than satisfied with this sequel
one user gave the feature and his main
villain Kang a strong endorsement
tweeting out quantumania so much fun
lots of heart too and Kang oh my another
user also gave Kang some Praise In
addition to claiming that Quantum Mania
is one of the best MCU movie experiences
in recent memory yet another person
tweeted a similar sentiment stating that
they haven't had the same level of fun
with an MCU flick since the release of
2021's Spider-Man no way home meanwhile
one person went so far as to predict
that quantumania will become something
of a cult classic writing it's got a
certain campiness to it similar to the
Star Wars prequels and will get better
as the movies that sets up add more
context
on second thought no not really no no in
many viewers estimations quantumania has
it all so they're not paying any mind to
what the far less enthusiastic critics
have to say about it but even though
many moviegoers seem to have enjoyed
themselves drawing their Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania screenings not
everyone that went to go see it walked
away with high opinions of it as one
person wrote I apologize to Thor love
and thunder Quantum Mania is officially
the worst Marvel movie wait for this to
come out on Disney Plus in another tweet
they went on to call it the weakest
installments in the Ant-Man Trilogy
another Twitter user sums up their
underwhelming experience with a simple
well but Quantum Mania was certainly a
movie they go into specifics in a
follow-up tweet expressing their belief
that the CGI writing and acting are
lacking in a similar vein some users
were let down by the film's visuals and
the score especially given the Whimsical
subtitle Quantum mania one tweet offers
some strong critiques of the sequel in
their post quantum is a call for help
this feature length and credit scene
packs a deafening scale of Noise with
only cursory concerns for creativity it
seems that several people agreed that
Quantum Mania is another in a recent
string of disappointing Marvel Studios
efforts of course these positive and
negative reactions to Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania only account for a
small section of MCU fans once the film
is out for a while it'll be interesting
to see whether General consensus of The
Wider fan base Falls
thank you